Have you ever wondered what the world's longest
ongoing war is? I have been fascinated
with this border for a very long time,
and a few months ago I went to just go see
what it looked like and I found something kind
of insane. So one of the major ways that North
and South Korea fight each other today is with
speakers. There is an ongoing battle between
North and South Korea on who can blast the loudest
propaganda or music at each other. South Koreans
will blast like K-Pop and all sorts of things.
Sometimes they'll just like make fun of North
Koreans on a hot day for not having, like, movie
theaters they can go into with air conditioning.
North Korea, on the other hand, will just blast
like communist propaganda like these operas from
the Soviet times. And they will get so loud to
the point where it will become like damaging, like
will break glass. So they've actually had to like,
like come to some agreement to come to the
table and be like, no more speaker wars.